y
[Música]
al menos 75 reclusos murieron en una
serie de motines que estallaron
simultáneamente en tres prisiones del
asignado sistema penitenciario de
ecuador- según las autoridades están
relacionadas con choques de bandas
criminales que se financian del
narcotráfico
la pandemia de kobe 19 agravó la crisis
de hambre en américa latina según la ong
acción contra el hambre la inseguridad
alimentaria pasó en la región de 3.4
millones de personas a un total de 10
millones los países de centroamérica
perú y colombia son los más afectados
naciones unidas- piden una mayor
protección social
tiger woods se está recuperando luego de
una compleja cirugía debido a lesiones
ortopédicas importantes en su pierna a
consecuencia de un grave accidente
automovilístico
el golfista llegó al hospital con
fracturas expuestas en tibia y peroné-
según un comunicado mucho se encuentra
consciente y receptivo
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 sierra blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos en el
ecuador donde unos 75 reclusos murieron
durante motines en tres centros
penitenciarios del país según las
autoridades los enfrentamientos se
originaron por la disputa entre dos
bandas por el control de las prisiones y
el tráfico de estupefacientes en el
penal de turing de la ciudad de cuenca a
unos 470 kilómetros al sur de la capital
ecuatoriana se contabilizaron 33 reos
muertos otros 34 fallecieron una presión
de guayaquil y otros 8 en la en la de
cotopaxi a unos 80 kilómetros se quitó
los motines se produjeron tras una
requisa efectuada por el personal
penitenciario que encontró armas de
fuego con las que presuntamente se
pretendía atentar contra líderes de una
de las bandas en disputa
se activan al mismo tiempo que hace
tres centros de privación de libertad
donde tenemos alrededor del 70 por
ciento de la población penitenciaria de
todo el ecuador
dos grupos tratando
de encontrar
un liderazgo delictivo al interior de
los centros de privación de la libertad
el líder opositor venezolano juan guaidó
afirmó que continuará trabajando para
que se celebren elecciones libres en su
país pese a considerar que existen
amenazas en su contra y luego de que la
contraloría reiteró la inhabilitación
del dirigente para ejercer cargos
públicos por 15 años
la contraloría afirmó que su decisión se
debe a la negación de guaitó y otros 27
diputados de presentar una declaración
jurada de patrimonio tras dejar sus
cargos el pasado 5 de enero entretanto
el nuevo parlamento controlado por el
chavismo pidió al gobierno de maduro
declarar persona non grata y expulsar a
la embajadora de la unión europea en
caracas tras sanciones del bloque contra
19 funcionarios venezolanos
que se declaré persona no grata a la
representante de la unión europea
el idioma no levanto puede exhortar a
que se revisen
las condiciones en las que existe una
oficina europea aquí en venezuela la ong
acción contra el hambre hizo publicó un
informe en el que advierte el aumento
del hambre en américa latina' la
inseguridad alimentaria pasó en la
región de 3.4 millones de personas a un
total de 10 millones preocupan
especialmente centroamérica perú y
colombia- naciones unidas pide una mayor
protección social
el informe de luís muñoz
américa latina fue la región donde hubo
un mayor aumento del hambre en 2020 son
10 millones de personas en situación de
inseguridad alimentaria el triple que
antes de la llegada del cob y 19 así lo
advirtió en conversación con france24
carlos caramella representante del
programa mundial de alimentos de la onu
las encuestas están confirmando y el
acceso en ocasión es la primera
necesidad preocupa a centroamérica
especialmente las comunidades rurales
del llamado corredor seco el informe
reveló que sólo una de cada diez
familias encuestadas cuentan con una
seguridad alimentaria adecuada cuando la
pandemia entonces todo se cerró ya no
nos dejaban salir entonces ya no
podíamos trabajar para poder traer los
alimentos a la casa en sudamérica el
foco está puesto en perú donde las ollas
comunes aumentaron de 337 a más de 1300
con la llegada del cobi 19 son cocinas
comunitarias vecinales impulsadas por
mujeres
de emergencia alimentaria también
preocupa colombia una encuesta 34 mil
familias reveló que el 80 por ciento de
ellas en su mayoría migrantes
venezolanas no cubren sus necesidades
básicas la onu pide un mayor esfuerzo
gubernamental el ampliamente del alcance
de los sistemas canciones de protección
social es una medida fundamental es una
medida que naturalmente exige también
una serie de otras otras medidas
relacionadas con la capacidad de
registrar por ejemplo los migrantes
irregulares según las naciones unidas la
pandemia deja 45 millones de nuevos
pobres en américa latina' efectos que
van de la mano del impacto del cob y 19
la región concentra una tercera parte de
contagios pese a tener menos del 10 por
ciento de la población mundial
y el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden mantuvo su primera reunión
bilateral con el primer ministro
canadiense yo sin trudeau los líderes
reunidos de manera virtual
reiteraron los lazos de amistad que unen
a las dos naciones volteando la página
tras una tensa relación con la
administración de donald trump los
líderes dijeron que planean trabajar
juntos para derrotar la pandemia de
scooby 19 y combatir los efectos del
cambio climático además anunciaron el
objetivo de lograr cero emisiones netas
para el año 2050
llegaron a italia los cuerpos de luca
atanasio embajador de ese país en la
república democrática del congo y de sus
guardaespaldas ambos asesinados junto al
chofer que los transportaba cerca de la
ciudad de goma el pasado lunes el primer
ministro mario draghi acompañó a los
familiares de las víctimas y mientras el
avión que los traía a los ataúdes
aterrizaba en el aeropuerto de roomba
los miembros de la cámara baja del
parlamento rindieron homenaje a los
fallecidos con un minuto de silencio y
con aplausos el ministro de relaciones
exteriores el y luigi de mayo calificó
el hecho como descorazonador y exigió
respuestas detalladas a naciones unidas
la misión se llevó a cabo tras la
invitación de naciones unidas y el
trayecto del convoy se realizó en el
marco organizacional establecido por el
programa mundial de alimentos por esta
razón le solicitó inmediatamente a la
apm a en broma y a la onu involucrando
directamente al secretario general
antonio gutiérrez que entreguen un
reporte detallado del ataque
del programa mundial de alimentos y
continuamos con más noticias
tiger woods sufrió graves lesiones en
ambas piernas después de que su vehículo
se saliera de la carretera cerca de los
ángeles en eeuu según los expertos el
golfista tuvo mucha suerte de sobrevivir
tuvo que ser operado y se encuentra
recuperándose en un hospital e según
informó su equipo veamos el siguiente
informe
un todoterreno volcado y destrozado ya
se inmóvil justo al lado de esta
carretera de los ángeles esta fue la
escena donde pocas horas antes la
leyenda del golf tiger woods perdió el
control de su vehículo y se estrelló el
martes por un breve momento el mundo del
golf esperó con la respiración contenida
preocupado por que boots pudiera estar
gravemente herido o algo peor
quiero decir es algo que me revuelve el
estómago ya sabes me duele ver a uno de
mis mejores amigos teniendo un accidente
espero que esté bien
pero cuando el ayudante del sheriff
asomó la cabeza por el parabrisas y le
preguntó su nombre se escuchó una lúcida
respuesta tiger había escapado a lo peor
directa es muy afortunado que el señor
gusta haya podido salir vivo de esto de
la naturaleza de su vehículo el hecho de
que llevaba el cinturón de seguridad
diría que aumentó en gran medida la
probabilidad de que le salvará la vida
la gravedad del impacto fue sin embargo
inmediatamente evidente el ganador de
quince meier se había lesionado
gravemente ambas piernas y fue llevado a
cirugía llegando con fracturas expuestas
en tibia y peroné las reacciones se
sucedieron con personajes como michael
tyson jack nicklaus y el expresidente
donald trump deseando una pronta
recuperación al hombre considerado el
mejor golfista de la historia la
pregunta obvia para los aficionados es
si woods podrá volver a jugar golf
y finalizamos con información deportiva
hablamos de los octavos de final de la
liga de campeones de europa en los
encuentros de ayer el chelsea venció de
visitante al atlético de madrid por 10
el bayern de múnich venció a italia en
italia a 4-1 al action y hoy se
enfrentan el atalanta de italia contra
el real madrid y el borussia
mönchengladbach se medirá frente al
manchester city- esto pasará el día de
hoy
y esta manera llegamos al final de la
informativa en france24 continúa con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias feliz día
[Música]
nuestros equipos recogen los testimonios
de los que viven